on prime crime
so certain that she's not coming back
a missing person's case that turns into
something else it's really hard to hide
a body in the best of circumstances but
to hide your own body is a whole other
level the interviews the investigation
and the drama if you guys think i did
something
arrest me and haul me in because i
didn't
[Music]
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime this is where we
do a deeper dive into the most high
profile and memorable true crime cases
when a woman suddenly goes missing
that's when the questions start
hi how are you
any luck no
no okay can we come in
it's april 26 2013 in pittsfield
wisconsin
law enforcement are about to begin an
eerie investigation
[Music]
the voice you're hearing is that of 67
year old james prokopovic and your wife
was not around not at that time i got up
started a pot of coffee
and sometimes she's down the basement or
whatever and i hollered for her and
hollered for it and i thought maybe she
fell asleep down there sure
yeah i went down she wasn't there went
upstairs and looked i looked all over
through the house
couldn't find her
prokapovic tells law enforcement that
his wife of over 20 years 59 year old
victoria prokopovic suddenly
disappeared first thing i did i jumped
in the truck
and i rode every road
i went up and down
because she does like to go for a walk
i was one of the first detectives to
have responded to the
proposed residents our first-line
responders our police officers had been
on scene for a number of hours and they
had been utilizing numerous uh
search efforts
did she leave her purse yep purchase
here should she have a driver's license
yeah that's right all right okay
but no credit card no so she wouldn't
have uh jumped on a plane no no no
my concern was heightened when i began
to learn and understand who our victim
was in this case
does she have a job nope she doesn't
work she's on disability
for what
depression and stuff she's done
psychiatrists care
her psychiatrist did testify
he testified to the diagnosis that he
gave her as being bipolar disorder
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
and anxiety disorder she was also
suffering from
borderline personality disorder
she had surgery
she had a colostomy
she had the bag on for about three and a
half to four months i know she was
really depressed
about this surgery because she did have
problems with control over the balls
that physically changes how your body
functions and for someone who is already
suffering from serious mental illness
it's absolutely going to compound the
depressive symptoms that she experienced
there could be an ominous possibility
she attempted suicide
once about
six seven years ago yeah she overdosed
on they figured it was aspirin
i honestly god thinks she may have
finally yeah
because she attempted suicide
this operation
really
threw her into a yeah
yet there's a serious issue with this
theory
if victoria killed herself
where's her body
jim why are you so certain that she's
not coming back
i just had that gut feeling rolling i
don't know
fast forward three months and
investigators still haven't found
vicki's body they called james back in
for an
if you know us to interview off
she would take some things that are you
would think
if she was to hurt herself she has no
means of fighting about it
it's really hard to hide a body in the
best of circumstances but to hide your
own body is a whole other level
in my line of work i have to go on
common sense you guys have a farmhouse
in a pretty rural area no car no bicycle
no public transportation that's out
there no cabs
any really no friends she goes missing
during a short period of time at night
what does that leave
me
with
james informs investigators about
something victoria had said
that is particularly chilling
she said if she was going to do it again
she was going to do it nobody would find
her that's the words that came out of
her mouth
it's definitely quite a compelling
statement
we were able to verify that
something along those lines was indeed
set
the victim in this case vicky had
recanted her story and apologized to her
daughter for making that statement when
we researched
vicki's medical history
her past episode called self-harm
they weren't
true genuine attempts to actually end
her life we found them to actually be
pleased for help
if vicky though was actually harmed
where's the evidence
i had nothing to do with her
disappearance
you know if anything would occur in that
officer there's no way it would be put
back together
that's absolutely true if this was
something that was done in the home well
of course her dna would be in the home
because she lived there of course her
fingerprints would be in the home
because she lived there you know if it
was a situation let's say where it was a
strangulation
there wouldn't necessarily be blood
coming up when james is further
questioned
things get heated
this is i'm getting ready where i'm
gonna want an attorney pretty soon
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate lawn crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
guys she'd been gone before for two
three four hours sometimes and she'd
come home again if you wanna live with
this day i've gone for 20 some years you
know what i'm trying to tell you
it's july 2013 out in wisconsin
investigators are speaking with james
prokopovic about his wife victoria who
disappeared without a trace a few months
back
james is adamant he doesn't know what
happened to victoria but does suggest
she may have actually killed herself
especially since she attempted suicide
in the past right now i'm at the point
where i hate her i hate her for what
she's doing to this family
investigators then hone in on some of
the odd behavior of james
they start with the day of the
disappearance
the police
i
said
she has the right to
do what she wants and disappear
we were there to recreate
what actually happened
what's normal
what's abnormal so you decided to go to
work yeah
and
this was despite
the fact that you thought it was
somewhat of an emergency that she wasn't
wrong not an emergency a little bit
unusual
however on the flip side if the whole
thing is a sham and it's a complete lie
uh it's very difficult
i didn't call around home
before i left for work can you explain
that to me i just didn't
there's also how james has been acting
since his
i'm talking wife
perfect strangers like the search
parties and what they say they say is
that that it just it strikes them as odd
they watch you mowing your lawn while
these complete strangers to you and
vicky take their time out of their day
to
search for your wife i know i understand
that i'm going to live my life the way i
want to live my life if people don't
like it they can move on
i i'm not one to sit and dwell
he's able to move on pretty quickly
it is certainly possible that someone
who is experiencing grief would not want
to experience the emotions associated
with the grief
some individuals will compartmentalize
i don't eat
how come you don't eat how come you
don't sleep i i don't know what i don't
sleep though i don't know how long has
this been happening
since she's been gone the not eating and
sleeping can 100
be
signs and symptoms of grief but the
other thing is true too where having
difficulty sleeping and not being able
to eat could actually be signs of guilt
as the weight prices on him more and
more year after year time after time
as the interview goes on
james temper begins to flair
[Music]
when he's asked certain things that he's
not able to explain
uh he
would erupt in anger that obviously
didn't work with us that did not cause
us to walk away
he may have hurt himself
is it possible that under those
circumstances you may have helped
fountain
no
that's it i want an attorney i'm done
you're accusing me of something
i swear to god i had nothing to do
with my wife's disappearance
it doesn't take a lot of imagination to
see
the capacity of someone to become that
angry and
what they may be capable of
during a more civil portion of the
interview
james reveals a very important piece of
information
he's been seeing an old girlfriend
so what is that where you met this other
girl yeah she
happened to meet her
there was a long-standing
history between those individuals that
he really really minimized so you know
he
immediately became a curious to us
up next the pressure on james
intensifies
i almost wish i was dead right now
i'm getting so tired of this
you are so ready willing and evil
to vomit
i i
can't sit and dwell on a problem
it's 2015. two years after victoria
prokapovic suddenly disappeared from her
wisconsin home investigators still don't
have an answer as to what happened to
the missing wife and mother what they do
know is that something seems a bit off
with victoria's husband james he claimed
he woke up and victoria was gone he even
suggested that she may have killed
herself a questionable theory
interestingly shortly after victoria
vanished
james began dating a former girlfriend
kathy friday
any indication that he had something to
do
i
truly believe him he says i did not have
anything to do with
so what's the
what's the best guesstimate is she
somewhere else alive nope
in the search for more answers
investigators questioned james again in
summer 2016. so i want you to tell
guys got me do you remember no
okay but it was like three and a half
years ago you're asking me where i sat
at
your table
my god man
anger in his eyes
was just so apparent
uh and he was angry that we once again
came back to ask a question
when
you have loving supporting family
members
they are eager
they generally are begging you to please
investigate more
do exactly what you did i walked over
here i said
okay she didn't answer okay then i went
here went down in the basement
thought she was down here
down the steps
honey
okay
do you remember why it is that you felt
the importance to look in every because
she tried to kill herself down here in
the basement once that's why okay
the investigators asked james to reenact
his search efforts the morning his wife
went missing
you're driving around what are you
thinking what are you looking at i'm
just looking for somebody walking down
the road
and had vicky ever been this far away
from the house walking no
no
first of all he's under the influence of
beer but he's doing it he was just
bulletproof he was very interfaceable
and i might have missed the road out
here and that's perfectly understandable
jesus christ you're asking me stuff
three and a half years ago what roads
did i go to i'm sorry roman i just don't
remember
when the investigators visit james a few
months later his outlook becomes grim
i'm 71 i hope the hell i have a heart
attack and die
i'm tired of worrying
i wish you guys would find her deceased
or alive i don't care and then if she
comes back alive good
then everybody will look foolish and all
you're doing is waiting for me to say
something a little bit different then
you say oh he's lying to us now we got
him going
and in 2019 that's exactly what happened
when we return james's words come back
to haunt him
you lied on the stand today
i did that i'll admit that but i do not
know where she is
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again judge
caprio rules with common sense i was
having contractions i was rushing to the
hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had clearly
judge he's been in a court before
get caught in providence
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre law and crime is
the only network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the law on crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is law and crime
my gut feeling says she found some place
to do it and we're not going to fight
her
for six years the 2013 disappearance of
mother and wife victoria prokopovic
baffled investigators while her husband
james maintained she may have killed
herself or ran off
law enforcement always kept a close eye
on him they would question james over
the years about his alibi as well as his
odd behavior
and then the web of lies
started to unravel
a number of years into the investigation
we were able to determine that when jim
was out in the middle of the night and
had relayed that he was searching for
his wife we were able to show that
he was not where he said he was
the real turning point though for james
concerned his girlfriend kathy friday
the couple always claimed they randomly
ran into each other after victoria's
disappearance
and then you ended up at the casino and
that's where you spent some money and
ran into her
however
when they testify at a secret court
hearing in 2019
their troubles are about to begin
you're under arrest
kathy's been placed under arrest
now when she took the sand
she got the same admonishment
that you did
we know
that there are some things that weren't
true
the meeting at the casino
did not happen
no it did not
roman and i believed for years we knew
that they were lying to us but until
those lies are actually exposed
that just was a surreal moment
how does the casino story how does that
come about
be honest with me we just figured it'd
be better than
saying we met and shacked up right away
the first night
but i do not know where she is don't
worry
i'll admit i killed her i killed her
there i killed her cathy had nothing to
do with i mean
i don't know
i don't know where she is
i believed him when he said it however i
didn't take it as necessarily a
confession he was willing to do and say
and he verbalized as such anything that
he could in order to be able to get
kathy not to
suffer any of the consequences for his
behavior
at the time of james arrest a new theory
circulated about what he did to victoria
jim what would happen to a body if you
put it in those sludge ponds where you
worked
i don't always probably never find it
he's obviously very comfortable with the
rural areas nearby and knew that a
sludge pond is something that would be
very hard to search and it would be very
hard to recover a body do you think the
police can prove
you killed your wife
if we don't have a key body
i've heard people being convicted about
fighting the body so i assume yes
and that's what the government tried to
do
james prokopovic was charged with first
degree intentional homicide obstruction
and perjury in connection with
victoria's death
after eight years he finally went on
trial
it is incredibly difficult to prosecute
a case without a body because you don't
know what really happened to the person
is it possible that he was wrongfully
accused of course anything is possible
in this world but is it reasonable the
defense that
the the victim vicky
killed herself and somehow hid her own
body defies logic and common sense you
had a man that very quickly moved on
with a new woman and this woman was in
the picture during the time of the
marriage to vicky nothing he was saying
was lining up with the evidence that
they had
prosecutors also presented the jury with
one more crucial piece of evidence
james allegedly told two inmates that no
one would be able to identify his
missing wife as there would be no blood
nor teeth
as to the offense of first degree
intentional homicide the verge has been
marked guilty
after a jury convicted procopovics of
homicide obstruction and perjury the
75-year-old was sentenced to life in
prison without the possibility of parole
as for kathy friday after she was
convicted of obstruction and perjury she
was found dead in her jail cell from an
apparent suicide
i don't think she knew the truth he
withheld that from her
kathy's uh death is just yet another
tragedy
in this particular case that has
resulted based on joe's actions
our mom remains missing
and we can we will continue searching
and i would hope
that with time
we could find
find forgiveness and peace in this
tragedy
with regards to binding her body
there is a possibility he may talk to
someone in prison there's a possibility
that on his deathbed he may feel some
guilt or remorse there's also the
possibility of with climate change and
things shifting maybe her body may
actually emerge from where she was
buried
i do hope for her family's sake that
they do get that final closure and if
they do not they are at least at peace
that justice was served and that
wherever she is she is in a better place
and there you have it what started out
with suspicion ended in a conviction and
sentence yet that doesn't mean that
everything is settled at the time of
this recording we still don't know where
victoria's body is and we're getting no
answers from james so it seems that
while there's some closure in this case
as of right now there's still more that
victoria's loved ones want and need to
know
that's all we have for you here on prime
crime leave us your comments on
instagram and twitter with the hashtag
primecrime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
[Music]
you